[Music]
if you wish to make progress
then be content to appear senseless and
foolish in externals
do not make it your wish to give the
appearance of knowing anything
and if some people think you to be an
important personage distrust yourself
for be assured that it is no easy matter
to keep your moral purpose
in a state of conformity with nature and
at the same time to keep externals
but the man who devotes his attention to
one of these two things must inevitably
neglect the other
in chapter 13 of the end caridian
epictetus is
reminding us of a choice that inevitably
we we have to make
and we don't really have a choice about
whether we want to
make this choice it's just about
which direction we're going to go with
it and if we
confuse ourselves or mislead ourselves
about being able to have things both
ways so the two terms of the choice you
could say the two
options are on the one hand what he's
calling externals to
ectos the things that are outside of our
control
but which we often view
as goods and and so long as we
mistakenly view them as goods for
ourselves or
indeed even the good our desire is
naturally going to be attracted to them
and in so far as we see
them as as bad things or their
deprivation is bad
then um we're going to feel a sense of
aversion towards them
and that's one side the other side
is having our moral purpose or our
faculty of choice what it is that we
really are
at our core in accordance with nature
and and let's remind ourselves too that
this doesn't mean
nature is in you know what we observe
human beings to be doing all the time
when we
see people acting badly and we say oh
it's just human nature
what we're talking about here is a fully
developed a fully
realized a fundamentally good
human nature that is really what we're
all
hankering for striving for but but often
getting wrong
in the process and epictetus is telling
us look you can focus on one of these or
you can focus on the other but you can't
focus
on both and if you tell yourself that
you're going to focus on both and
somehow it's going to all work out
you're really deceiving yourself and
setting yourself up for problems
so he gives us three uh bits of advice
about how we would put this into
practice those are the
the things that follow after he says if
you wish to
make progress then these are the things
you have to accept he says
be content to appear senseless and
foolish
in externals so what does that mean
be all right with other people
and even perhaps yourself when you
engage in self-recrimination
saying yeah that that that just was not
the the right thing to do you know if
you wanted to maximize your income
why were you focusing on on this you
know
stoic philosophy and its exercises if
your goal
was to you know as dale carnegie said uh
make friends and influence people
uh or if you wanted to you know get the
corner office
if you wanted to get this if you wanted
all these things that are external to us
or even think about your body
because the body is something external
for epictetus if you wanted to be
stylish
then why did you not find out what the
current style was
all those things you know or the lack of
those things
is what makes people appear to other
people
and perhaps even to themselves if they
internalize that
to be foolish to not manage their
externals
well if you really think though like the
stoics do
that externals are indifferent they're
neither good nor bad
then why would you put all that
attention say
into style or design or
making a ton of money or or this or that
all these things that are external
you wouldn't do that so if you're going
to
try to make progress you've got to learn
how to be okay with people saying
that person doesn't have it all together
they're not doing
what they need to do if their goal is x
because the stoic's goal is not that the
stoic's goal is having their
moral purpose or faculty of choice in
accordance with nature
the next one that he says is
do not make it your wish to give the
appearance of knowing
anything so this isn't just a matter of
you know putting on heirs and
trying to appear to be more
knowledgeable than you actually are
uh you know if you're studying stoic
philosophy and you've read some
epictetus you actually do know
something and if you're paying attention
to uh how it pans out when you put it
into
practice and how other people act and it
functions as a lens you actually do know
something but that doesn't mean that you
need to tell other people that you know
it
and it doesn't even mean that it would
be productive for you to tell other
people that you know something again
they may you may know something they may
not recognize that
if you try to make an issue of that and
show them how they've got things
fundamentally
wrong and are being irrational are you
know engaging in sort of
self-contradiction
or being inconsistent all those sorts of
things that is not going to
be a message that they can hear until
they're receptive to hearing it and that
may be
never you know depending on who the
person is
so you don't have to
make an issue out of knowing anything
and as a matter of fact
you should probably learn how to be okay
with other people saying
that guy really doesn't know anything
you know again the evidence for that
would be
well he's not you know doing the sorts
of things that that the rest of us are
doing
which is really not a good criterion for
whether you know something or not
the third thing that he says builds off
of all of this
he says if some people think you to be
an important personage
distrust yourself now that's a very
interesting
bit of advice is he talking
about you know you getting
celebrity status or having lots and lots
of facebook friends and people liking
your
your uh witty statements or or your
political observations or
whatever else it is or is he talking
about
other people trusting you with with uh
authority and then people looking up to
you because of that
is he talking about um having talents
that you've developed and and you know
other people saying
that person really has done a lot i i
want to be like like them
well it could be any of those cases it
could even be
making progress in stoic philosophy
right although that's probably a little
less likely to be to be you know
put put on a pedestal then say athletic
prowess
or business acumen or whatever else we
want to say that our culture celebrates
now there is something to that
when other people who
are primarily looking at externals and
are not paying attention to
their you know the basis of their
personality the core of who they
are and whether it's in good shape or
bad shape and whether they would like to
fix it or
or work on it and if they're not
actually doing that wholeheartedly but
they're paying primarily attention to
externals
they're bad judges and so if they
think that you're really doing well from
a stoic perspective that should set off
some red flags or some alarm bells
you know if they're thinking that you're
doing really great
either it's totally indifferent and
you're not doing great necessarily at
all or you're
actually doing the wrong things
if you if you wind up making a ton of
money
well that's not a bad thing or a good
thing
maybe you just happen to be in the right
place at the right time
maybe the things that you did you know
with integrity were rewarded although
that's very often not the case it's
usually the opposite
or maybe you followed the crowd
maybe you gave into the culture
maybe you cut yourself off from making
progress along the stoic path
there's also a tendency that we ought to
think about here that i think epictetus
is hinting at
which is when other people are making a
lot of us when they're telling us oh
you're such a small guy
oh you're you know you're so invaluable
oh you you are
really a go-getter you you know you're
the best scholar here
whatever it happens to be it's easy for
us
uh if we're not already totally
you know at the end of the the stoic
path as the sage it's easy for us
to find our desires and aversions that
are still
hooked out in things out there in the
world particularly in how other people
think about us
to start getting swayed by that and to
ignore the fact that there should be a
little voice in the back of her head
saying
watch out it's easy to start ignoring
that and say well you know in this case
maybe they actually are right and
epictetus is saying
look if if you're going to pursue the
stoic path
it's got to be a 100 percent commitment
or else it's going to fail sooner or
later you're going to get dragged back
into external things so he says be
assured
it's no easy matter to keep your moral
purpose in a state of conformity with
nature
and at the same time to keep externals
you can maintain one or
you can maintain the other if you try to
maintain both and there's plenty of
externals that would tell you you can
maintain both right you can have it all
you're going to lose all of it or at
best you're going to get the externals
you're definitely not going to
find the contentment the tranquility
the not being hindered the uh
happiness that lies along the stoic path
because you're not going to
bring your moral purpose in accordance
with nature
so he says the person who devotes his
attention to one of these two things
must inevitably neglect the other
so if it really is the case that
one does have to neglect the other one
you have to choose wisely and most
importantly
you have to actually make a choice
if you make it your will that your
children and your wife and your friends
should live forever
you are silly for you are making it your
will that things not
under your control should be under your
control and that what is not
your own should be your own in the same
way too
if you make it your will that your slave
boy be free from faults you are a fool
for you are making it your will that
vice be not vice but something else
if however it is your will not to fail
in what you desire
this is in your power wherefore exercise
yourself
in that which is in your power each
man's master
is the person who has the authority over
what the man wishes
or does not wish so as to secure it or
take it away
whoever therefore wants to be free let
him neither wish for anything
nor avoid anything that is under the
control of others or else he is
necessarily
a slave
chapter 14 confronts us with some of our
irrational desires and going beyond that
though the word that that he uses here
is not just desire like aaraxis but the
verb
uh thales to choose to to will
to to want something to be a certain way
so
there is the element of desiring and
then there's also the element of
choosing or committing and he talks
about several different
things that it's it's fundamentally
wrong-headed
to to desire or to wish things to be
that way he says
if you make it your will that your
children and your wife
and your friends should live forever
you're being silly
why is that the case well you know
remember the stoics were materialists so
they're not talking about some soul
going off to
an afterlife or anything like that so if
we confine ourselves just to
bodily existence if you expect that any
given person
people that you do feel affection for
is going to live forever you're really
being kind of crazy
you're expecting things to be different
in your case
than they are for all the rest of
humanity
past present and presumably future
so it's it's setting yourself up
for not only failure and disappointment
but but great
heartbreak if you don't you know
take account of the fact that your your
wife
your spouse you know husband
your children your parents friends
whoever else that you're attached to is
going to eventually
encounter death um you're you're
you know if you're going to deny that or
pretend like that's not the case
it's going to happen either they'll die
before you or or
you'll you know they'll die after you in
which case it's it's not really an issue
but if they do die before you you're
gonna what are you gonna do when you
have to deal with it
um he says you're making it your will
that things not under your control
should be
under your control and that what is not
your own
should be your own so this is a very
important application
of that fundamental distinction between
what is
in our control or in our power and what
is not
what is our own task or our own business
and what isn't you could say that it's
okay to hope
perhaps in some sense realizing that
those hopes are not going to be real or
not going to
to come to any fruition that um one will
live forever or one's one's parents or
children or
or spouse or friends will live forever
but um the stoics would would say that
that's rather misguided
that sort of hope is not based in
anything and this is where the stoics
are going to differ from
quite a few other uh philosophical and
also theological
traditions um
if we're going to be consistent about
how to
approach things that are not in our
power this is an example of things that
we just can't
allow ourselves to wish for and if we do
find ourselves wishing for it
then we need to go through a process of
figuring out well why is it that i want
things to be
other than i know them to be why is it
that i
i want things so badly to be
an exception to to the general rule and
it's understandable
in the case of of death why that would
why that would be the case
but understanding that doesn't change
the the situation
he goes on and he says in the same way
too if you make it your will
that your slave boy be free from faults
you're a fool
that's a foolish thing to do foolish in
the sense of being the opposite
of wisdom why is it a foolish thing
to wish your servant or really anything
else that we might talk about that's in
a subordinate position
to be free of faults well to start with
are you
free of faults you're in a higher
position and you're not even free of
faults
do you actually know anybody who's free
of faults who never makes mistakes
who never misinterprets what's going on
who doesn't say stupid things from time
to time
who you know doesn't trip occasionally
well you know
you're expecting that the things that
are beneath you are going to do that
or the things that are subordinated to
you in some way
why would that possibly be the case
i think for a lot of us today it's not
just in terms of the people that we deal
with
most of us don't have servants but we do
have people who are placed in a
subordinate position
oftentimes temporarily in relation to us
like clerks and retail stores
or customer service workers or people
who are on the tech support line
but we do have technology and don't we
often
get upset with our technology when it's
not doing things the way that we
expect it to i mean by this point in
time
if we're going solely by induction by by
taking our a range of experiences
and generalizing from them we should
probably say when it comes to any given
computer
it's it's probably going to screw up
sooner or later when it comes to any
software upgrade
it's probably going to damage some
things and send
some you know some functions haywire
we shouldn't be so unrealistic about how
things are going to perform
those are things that are not in our
power uh in this case he talks about the
slave boy he says
you're making it your will that vice
be not vice but something else
we could apply this to so many other
things as well
think about uh family members or friends
who in one way or or another
are irrational about something could be
politics
it could be about sports it could be how
they treat other people
it could be you know about their their
life narrative
and you know how they portray themselves
and other people
you know if they really are off base
in things you're not going to be able
to you know steer them onto base
unless they decide at some point oh wow
my gosh i'm so screwed up
i don't want to be screwed up like this
i need to take some steps
and then you've actually got some some
opening some leverage some some room
where you know stoic philosophy or or
other you know approaches
could take root but until then so long
as they're you know established in that
if you're expecting irrationality not to
appear to be irrational
if you're expecting people who you know
fly off the handle at a given situation
to not fly
off the handle if you're expecting
somebody who you know to be a coward
to actually stick up for you and have
your back that's foolishness
you're expecting things to be totally
other
than they are and you can say yeah but
i'd like them to be that way
sure you can like them to be that way
and then you're being irrational
and that's just as bad as the person the
other person who's being irrational
isn't
it so he he goes on with this and he
says
um if however it is your will
not to fail in what you desire
this is in your power
the stoics teach that if we can confine
our desires
and our aversions to what really is in
our control
then we will never fail right
unless we choose to fail if we're going
to
desire all sorts of things that are
dependent upon another person
that are dependent on the stars aligning
just right
that are dependent on the technology not
letting us down
we're bound to be disappointed and we
should recognize that
so he goes on and he says wherefore
exercise yourself in that which is in
your power
now here's where he says something
really uh quite interesting
each man's master is the person who has
authority over what the man wishes
or does not wish so as to secure it or
to take it away
what is it to to be in charge to be
a master to be in control
it's to have power over the things
that other people desire now if your
desires are primarily oriented
around being a good person having your
personality squared away working upon
yourself
what what epictetus calls the realm of
the pro-erasus or the moral purpose
nobody else has control over that you
have control over that that's the
central message
of stoic philosophy you control the core
of your person
you control what you want to make of
yourself
what other people think about it that's
up to them
that's not in your control that will
never
be in your control except insofar as you
can bring power to bear upon them
if you want them to think a certain way
find out what you know sort of levers
you have and then you know start pulling
on those levers
but realize that that you know you're
you're essentially
being pulled on by other lovers in in
doing that yourself
it's better that you you don't worry so
much about how to get other people to do
what you want
and focus on actually getting you to do
what it is
that you recognize as good for you
as a way of improving yourself a way of
pruning away
those bad parts of yourself that are
causing you grief
that are causing you disappointment that
are causing you unhappiness
that are getting you into conflicts with
other people with yourself
it's better that you work on that than
that you worry about
you know what somebody else thinks or
what somebody else does
or whether it's fair or whether you know
they shot first or any of these these
sorts of things
because you don't have control over any
of that
and so so epictetus goes on
and he says whoever wants to be free
let him neither wish for anything nor
avoid anything that's under the control
of others
so if you want to be free then you
probably
can't care an awful lot about the
fashion industry
because the fashion industry is under
the control of others
even if you manage to break in most of
the time what you're dealing with are
other people's ideas
other people's preferences other
people's pushing other people's pulling
if it's politics now that's not to say
that the stoics would say withdraw from
politics
but there are there are ways to behave
as a good politician somebody with
integrity
most politicians don't most politicians
haven't throughout history
a lot of people get involved in politics
because they think they're going to fix
the world
they're going to make things better at
least in their their own little corner
and then they find out all the wheeling
and dealing and all the people pleasing
that they have to do
and the loss of integrity that goes
along with that
if you're going to buy into that sort of
sort of system
be prepared to be disappointed
especially in political races because
only one candidate can win right and
even when they win they often lose don't
they
um and we could go on and on and on if
your if your goal
is accumulating uh romantic
relationships
um that's highly dependent on on
somebody else isn't it
if your goal is to amass a ton of money
or to be
perfectly secure in terms of finances in
terms of
uh you know uh prepping or
or hoarding weapons or you know making
sure that nobody can do anything that
could possibly harm you
you can certainly spend a lot of time on
that but that's not
actually going to make you happy from
the stoic perspective
because all those things are dependent
on somebody else
oftentimes not just on somebody else but
on some things else
but so long as to go back to that thing
so long as
somebody has control over it you don't
have control over it and so
if you want to be happy you have to
be realistic about the way things are
and you have to confine
your desires and aversions and choices
to what it is that you really do have
control over
remember that you ought to behave in
life as you would
at a banquet as something is being
passed around it comes to you
stretch out your hand and take a portion
of it politely it passes on
do not detain it or it is not come to
you yet
do not project your desire to meet it
but wait until it comes in front of you
so act towards children so toward a wife
so toward
office so toward wealth and then someday
you will be worthy of the banquets of
the gods
but if you do not take these things even
when they are set before you but despise
them
then you will not only share the banquet
of the gods but share also their rule
for it was by so doing that diogenes and
heraclitus and men like them were
deservedly divine and deservedly so
called
epictetus likes metaphors and
he uses one here in chapter 15 that's
particularly striking
he talks about being at a banquet and
now this is presuming that you actually
do have some decent table manners that
you have some understanding about how to
comport yourself
in public at you know common meals
but here's what he says he says you
ought to behave in life as you would at
a banquet so that doesn't mean stuffing
your face
and getting drunk and you know falling
under the table or anything like that
he says as something is being passed
around it comes to you
stretch out your hand take a portion of
it politely
it passes on do not detain it
so you know you don't necessarily have
to think of a banquet think of a family
meal
here come the mashed potatoes i love
mashed potatoes
i've been waiting for the mashed
potatoes you dig
in and take all the mashed potatoes and
then like you know just pass on an empty
bowl to the next person
and say oops sorry it's all gone now
i had my turn no you take a polite
amount
and you know if you really like the
mashed potatoes hopefully there will be
enough for seconds if there aren't
enough for seconds
let it go right because that's what it's
like
to be good in a
situation with others and you might say
well wait a second aren't the stoics
supposed to not care about what other
people think
you're not supposed to make your
happiness dependent upon what other
people think
or allow your desires and aversions to
get entangled with that
but that doesn't mean that you don't
have to care at all what other people
think
why would you deliberately hurt somebody
else's feelings
why would you behave in an uncaring way
towards them
that's not not to have your pro-iracist
or moral moral faculty
in a state of accordance with nature
that's actually against nature
although you know you can say well
that's human nature yes that's damaged
uh beastial human nature that's not
developed human nature which is what you
ought to be
striving for so he says
it has not come to you yet do not
project your desire to meet it but wait
until it comes in front of you now this
is a metaphor about the table right
but you could think about how this would
apply in so many other cases
don't always be thinking about how
you're going to advance in your career
actually do the work at the time that
will result
perhaps if things work out right in you
advancing in your career
because if you're spending all your time
daydreaming about the corner office
or about getting you know more accounts
or about you know
when you're going to make full professor
or things like that
you're never going to do any real work
you can't just plan
all day long right and
we can say this about so many other
things as well and we can say this about
ourselves
as projects oh you know when i lose 50
pounds
then life is going to begin we used to
say something like that
in the army which was quite strange we'd
say when i get back to the world
or sometimes we'd say when i get back to
the real world
and i remember one time you know a
sergeant saying
what is wrong with you dummy you're in
the real world right now
this is it it could be over now
and and we can say similarly about all
these other things
that's that's what it is to allow the
dishes to pass
and not extend our desire out to them
but only allow it to to come out
when the dish is in front of us so he
says
act towards act in this way towards
children
towards a wife towards office towards
wealth
and someday you will be worthy of the
banquets of the gods
but if you do not take these things even
when they're set before you but
look down upon them the translation has
despised them but just it just means to
look down upon them
then you will not only share the banquet
of the gods but also share their rule
if you want to have the kind of life
that people look to and say that person
nobody can coerce them
they are in control of themselves in
control of their emotions
they they do what they want to do
because they they want something that's
realistic
that's something that that's feasible
but that requires
like he says that we
[Music]
don't take these things even when
they're before us why wouldn't we take
them
when they're before us well because
that's one way to practice
the virtues that are required for a
fully stoic life
like fortitude like endurance like
wisdom like justice
and he goes on and he gives us some some
interesting examples he says
it was by doing so that diogenes and
heraclitus
and men like them were deservedly divine
and deservedly so called diogenes
was the cynic philosopher who you know
actually
mouthed off even to an emperor that's
a lot of freedom right there now the way
that he secured that freedom was by
living in a barrel
and doing what he wanted in the
marketplace and putting up with people
beating him up
every once in a while but that
might be the cost of it heraclitus we
don't actually know
quite so much about as they did in
ancient times
because in part his his writings are
only present to us in fragments we have
a life of heraclitus
but heraclitus similarly had lived a
life
of freedom from convention of
freedom from the oppressive weight of
social pressure and so
if we behave like he says the way that
that
one ought to at a banquet and we apply
this
to our desiring and our thinking about
things and our feeling about things
we will be setting ourselves up for
freedom and for happiness
[Music]
you